for the diamondbacks and the miami
marlins the finale of a four-game set
and their d-back starter tonight
right-hander merrill kelly coming off
the loss against the mets in new york
last weekend when he walked five and
five and two three
and aguilar at second one out 3-2 to
dickerson
called strike three lou williams rings
them up on the cinco that appeared to be
inside
right fielder nice job by carson kelly
that time to get
around the baseball and as he's
receiving it the glove was coming back
toward the inside corner
coming up trevor rogers on the bump
tonight for the miami marlins has been
so good throughout this season that
1-8-9
era for him currently sits at sixth best
in the national league making his eighth
start here
in 2021 that surpasses last year's total
how imposing he is on the mound haven
smith has a base hit taken away what a
play by brian anderson at third
making a bid for another extra base hit
into the corner which has been the theme
for the d-backs but
andy makes a beautiful play he certainly
does a great start to
the game tonight from b.a
that not the fast ball instead the
slider a strikeout just the same and
there are two ways
you wondered how the diamondbacks are
going to approach rogers tonight are
they going to be aggressive or they're
going to sit all over the heater all
night long eduardo escobar who stands in
now
that's right handed here against rogers
pitch on the way and escobar rips one on
the line it's caught by miguel rojas
a second great defensive play in the
left side of the infield
in the bottom of the first rojas a
couple of steps back into his right
go for it made a great play josh rojas
talking about miguel rojas on the left
side no relation two two pitches
swinging and miss he tied him up with a
change up down and in and struck him out
left on left change up right there and
that's actually you know what's funny
it's it's
one of the toughest pitches because you
don't ever really see that as a lefty
and josh ross is taking that swing he's
going back to dugout going what was that
the lead-off walk still stands at first
there's that fastball upstairs three
strikeouts
step aside 2-1 pitch to sierra lefty
batter there's a line drive over the
shorts that base it left center field
it's gonna roll to the wall let's watch
sierra run he's in its second base
he'll take a turn but hang on there with
the lead off double so there's his first
extra base hit
sierra stays hot and he's making a
little bit of a statement here he wants
to stay in the lineup
101 out for miguel rojas kelly brings
home an 02.
chopper up the middle it's a base hit
for rojas
and sierra lost track of the ball for a
second but fortunately with the speed
is able to score and rojas slides into
second
collides with young and now miggy down
holding his left bicep
all sorts of confusion here on a play
that seems pretty routine
a bounding ball back through the box
good swing they were playing him to pull
i don't know why sierra is holding up
hillman's right in front of him
showing him got the ball he got back on
the mound knew that he you know had
missed his mark made a bad pitch
ended up out over the plate and got
turned around but it wasn't
a lot of energy a lot of misguided
emotion
like a guy who strikes somebody else
just walks off the mound
girlfriend tessa in the house yeah it's
the neighborhood
since the cutter out there merrill has
put that pitch away for the most part
this year but it came in handy that time
one-nothing miami
[Music]
castro came in in 219. he's got 14 hits
one home run three runs padded in and he
swings hits one to right
center field nobody's going to catch
that ball and goes
all the way to the warning track bounces
into the pool for a ground pool double
la castro's already at third base but
don't have to go back
so an automatic double here for la casio
to open this setting boy did he blast
that ball
well especially given the fact how
shallow this outfield plays
nobody in the world was going to catch
up to that one infield middle enfield
will play back
first pitch and a shot to center field
sierra has it
here's the tag here comes le castro to
the plate good throw
and he got in just in time 1-1
andy a chance to break a 1-1 tie here in
the sixth
[Applause]
and that's through for a base hit how
much did he need that
dickerson scores and the marlins take a
two to one lead
well that away ba there you go good
contact going the other way
a wide open hole to the right side and a
deep breath
and probably a little sigh of relief
from ba as well
that's why you find him in the fourth
spot in the lineup tonight he's put up
great numbers as a righty
rogers gets the strikeout they throw to
first and the runner
is back safely yeah trevor rogers
neighborhoods
they're all kinds of happy about a
performance tonight lincoln colleen mom
and dad
i don't know the presidents or the
commissioners of the take a seat club i
don't know
but uh certainly members we know that
3-2 and a called strike three
dots the inside corner with 97.
gets it done again nice job working all
the way back
to get young maybe his best fastball of
the night 97 miles an hour
cabrera on the move and
he is hurt and down something went wrong
halfway to second
and as drupal cabrera is hurt
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
an goodness jump over there first base
just blew a tire right there
leg buckled and he just couldn't come to
a stop he was running at full speed
make it seven trevor rogers in front of
family and friends not far from home
continues to look great 2-1-6
but if you go back to the beginning of
last year
he's second in slugging second and on
base and tied for
second in batting average there's a
ground ball through the right side base
hit aguilar comes through again
cooper scores mickey stops at third it's
the third hit of the night it's the
league leading 32nd rbi of the season
for the remarkable jesus aguilar
and the marlins pushed the lead to three
to one
dickerson into right field to base hit
miggy's into score
more runs in the seventh inning and
later for the marlins as they now make
it a 4-1 lead
12 of the last 13 games the diamondbacks
bullpen has given up a run
duvall into center and that will fall
for a base hit
here comes aguilar around third he'll
score the marlins tacking some run
on it's 5-1 another good swing
by duvall his second hit of the night
catches it off the end of the bat just a
little bit but
through the baseball and dumps it in
center field well that's right
part of the power package is the speed
package for aguilar
as he flies around third base and scores
standing up
so many extra base hits for the
diamondbacks in this series that looked
like it was ticketed for the corner
this one out to center field drifting
back is sierra
he's there it's a marlins win
they win the last two in this four game
series against the diamondbacks